foreign
abusing pain medication for over four
years now prescription pain medication
my husband and my family don't know that
I'm taking opioids pain medication first
of all thank you for saying that out
loud I'm really proud
[Music]
John deloney's show where we take real
calls from real people who are
struggling with their mental health with
their marriages with daily decisions
daily choices
if they're emotional health with their
kids with a million things
all of us are going through nonsense in
this world it's kind of got a gone a
little mad and this show is is designed
to be a light in the darkness and my
promise is I'm going to sit with you in
the darkness and we're going to figure
out the next step we're going to create
a path out of this thing and it might be
a long long journey or it might be a
light switch but we're gonna figure out
how we can get some light back in the
darkness if you want to be on the show
go to John deloney.com ask ask ask John
delaney.com ask and huge news
pre-order from my brand new book
building a non-anxious life
if you've been ride or die with our show
you know I've been talking about this
for a long long time the way we are
handling mental health chronic burnout
stress all the stuff that we hear
everywhere all over the place what we're
doing is not working
and this book is a deep dive into what
the problem is and more importantly what
do we do next what is the path out of
here in this book I've distilled it down
to make it as simple as possible it's
not a textbook I am a super nerd this is
the least nerdy book I could write it's
not full of a million citations it's not
full of a million big fancy you know PhD
words
I I tried to make this as simple as
possible for moms and dads like you and
like me who just want to do better for
our kids who want to have some peace in
our lives this book is for you so go to
John deloney.com 20 bucks for the
pre-order and you get a whole bunch of
other stuff including an automatic
download of a talk I gave recently on
one of the chapters in the book which
I'm just super hyped about so go to
johnolain.com and check it out okay
right before we came on you used to wrap
houses when you were a kid
yeah we used to go for those that don't
know what that means toilet papering
houses right and just just if you don't
know what that means you just get like 5
10 or me and my friend's case 90 rolls
of toilet paper and you throw them as
high as you can up in the trees and then
they gravity brings it down and you just
keep throwing it back up until it's just
covered just Google wrapping houses or
toilet papering houses it was amazing it
was an art form back yeah and the best
was if it would rain overnight and then
the next morning your mom was like
cleaned it up so awesome incredible
but so a friend of mine and I we had
this like war going on my senior year of
high school where pretty much every
other weekend one of us was doing
wrapping the other's house and my
crowning achievement was I forked his
entire front yard which means you take
plastic forks and just in a row the
entire front yard
his parents were not pleased as you can
imagine I figure it was free aeration
people pay for that
um we would take them and stick them in
and snap them off oh see that's just me
because we were mean that was just not
cool because that ruins your lawnmower
well it just shoots out your lawnmower
like missile it was not yeah we took it
way too fast we did it like all now I
did have a friend of mine that did this
to me they went and got every
um like election sign it was election
season every we used to do all the uh
real estate signs yeah and put five
thousand but then the real estate I get
it they got upset yeah but I did get in
trouble when I put um shaving cream on
his yard and I killed part of his front
yard oh that's his parents were pleased
nope that's just the cost of doing
business that's what I figured we went
way way way too far one year and we just
kind of killed it for everybody my two
my two favorite moments One time my dad
um I was a kid and I was asleep and some
some teenagers were wrapping our house
and my dad woke me up and he goes hey
get up come here and I didn't know what
it was and he goes come here and I could
see something was up and we he like was
crouched down and We snuck out the back
door and I thought it was so cool man
and he handed me the hose and he goes on
the count of three and he had a huge
bucket full of water and he goes one two
and he started whistling and screaming
and we ran on the couch and I thought I
was the coolest guy of all time ever and
my other one was my dad had a great
friend he was an attorney named Tim
power calling his name out on this show
guys awesome guys awesome Tim power
to say we annihilated his house is the
understatement I think we had an entire
case of toilet paper which back then was
90 rolls
it looked like it had a blizzard across
his house
and as one that we left and I was pretty
proud of him I was like like that's
going to be so awful to clean up like I
wouldn't want to be them we went home
and there was literally no reason this
is unprovoked this is just me and a
couple of teenage buddies like let's
just take a guy who's really great to us
and it's a good friend with my dad and
let's just ruin his entire week and so
we went in toilet papered his house
obnoxiously next morning like at eight
o'clock I have a knock on my door and
it's him it's Tim power
I was like oh you're dead you got busted
and he goes hey man I'm in a real bind
can you help me out and I was like what
happened he goes my house got like Well
Done wrapped last night I have this
thing coming up can I hire you to go
clean it up
and I was like yes you can so I cleaned
it up and he paid me a bunch of money it
was awesome and I waited like five years
maybe even longer than that in fact Tim
this is it this is me confessing this is
my confession I'm just telling you that
was me it was me and he paid for it
quite impressive it was good it makes me
sad that teenagers today because of
doorbell cameras and all that won't get
to do that if you wrapped a house today
they would call the cops because it used
to be it wasn't like you did it to
people you didn't like it was people you
liked it was your friend so fun and if
you woke up in your house with a toilet
paper and you were like yeah it was so
fun we had police officers drive by
they'd honked the horn they turned their
lights on I am running hot hidden bushes
from police officers and yeah like a
crowning achievement if your house gets
teeth it was it was like a oh my God I
have friends I got friends people love
me yeah yeah maybe I'll maybe I'll kiss
somebody one day it's gonna happen Kelly
you keep wishing Kelly it's coming all
right let's go out to Reno Nevada and
talk to
is it Lila Lila what's up Lila
Hi how are you doing we have a party and
how about you
um I'm okay kind of like nervous can't
believe I'm on the show I don't be
nervous at all the show's not even that
great what's up
so um I I kind of like had a question um
maybe uh hopefully you can help me
figure it out
can I control my feelings
um I get
um
I feel like down easy like if if I take
someone and don't text me back I like I
start Imagining the words
um and I start shopping stuff randomly
like whenever I feel like
I'm not good enough I start buying stuff
randomly it's not extremely like
thousands of dollars but I don't like it
like I buy stuff that I don't need and
then I'm like I shouldn't buy it why did
I buy it and then I saw like
um and I making me feel even worse
because like I'm spending money that
there's no need and so I like I start
feeling down and then
I don't know yeah you almost get into
that shame cycle right where you buy
something that you know you don't need
but it makes you feel a little bit
better and then you feel guilty that you
bought it and then you feel ashamed when
it shows up and then you get low and the
only way to make you feel better is that
you think is you go buy something else
and the whole thing starts over again so
it's like a circle and it never gets to
the point to feel good sure and I'm like
that's like I I listen a lot to your
show and a lot of shows like um you know
to self-improvement or minimalists and
stuff like that and I'm like I know I
don't need this
but at the moment I feel like oh this is
what's going to make me happy I know it
doesn't yeah well I'm really really
grateful that you called that means a
lot um let's back out a little bit
I'm gonna I'm gonna talk more about
feeling low how long have you felt low
it's it's uh it's uh it's not all the
time
um and that's another thing that I feel
ashamed of I'm marrying it and my
husband it's amazing he knows all this
like I I can talk to him about this kind
of stuff and he's always there for me
um so hold on hold on hey okay
I need you to hear me say this
it's okay if you if you get down
and it's okay to feel anxious you're not
there's not something wrong with you
you're not broken it doesn't mean you're
a bad wife it doesn't mean you don't
love your husband doesn't mean your
husband's not great
here's the deal it just simply means
your body's trying to get your attention
for some reason
and what we want to do is we want to get
to what's my body trying to tell me
and you hear how there's no shame in
that there's no guilt in that it's just
pure curiosity I wonder I wonder why
that I wonder why that is
and
I would wonder do you have some
girlfriends in your life some women in
your life that you go do things with
that you hang out with or are you are
you lonely no no
no tell me about
um they're they're great like uh I'm not
I'm not the one who did if I had a
problem I call I usually I just talk to
my husband
um but we hang out like often like at
least what different friends like you
know work and outside of work and stuff
like that so you have little ones
I'm sorry you have kids you have little
ones yeah one tell me about them
um choose she's good she's great you
know she's a kid she have a her moment
they
auditions it's a little bit push but
she's a great kid she had a good heart
so I remember it was a huge moment for
me when
I started tracking backwards
for me I think I've talked about this on
the show all the time
um I don't have a lot of impulse
shopping sometimes
um
but not usually usually my issue is I go
to junk food I go to go to trash like
unhealthy food
and
it was such a revelation to me when I
realized that almost every time I go
I'm either super exhausted and there's a
lot of real clear literature that
suggests
the more tired you are the more hungry
in the in the poorer the food choices
you make
but almost always there was some sort of
relational issue I was frustrated with
my wife my kids were driving me crazy I
was super annoyed with somebody at work
and I found myself mindlessly grabbing
junk food and I'm sure I could go down a
rabbit hole and figure out the
physiology I didn't really care what the
physiology was I just needed to know
that the trigger had something to do
with when my body felt exposed or lonely
or disconnected from folks
so going along those same lines I would
ask you
the times you can think back to when you
have
felt the need to sit down and impulse
shop to buy something
what usually starts that Domino hits
that first Domino that just rolls the
rest of them down
um if I can like if I like kabad is
usually
um either yeah stresser work or I've had
an argue with my husband or with my kids
or I feel like and
I don't know why like I feel like if if
I had a friend then and then I text you
know and if I know everyone's busy
everyone had the like button my head
it's like if they don't text me within a
few hours I was like are they mad at me
did I did anything today and I'm like
and I keep going like I don't remember
saying or doing anything but I'm like oh
but maybe I did and I didn't realize and
then that's when I feel like the anxiety
and then I'm like I just got online and
I started just look around on things to
try to distract my mind and then I end
buying things that I don't need and I
just you know they look good this look
cool I can do this with this yeah oh of
course I mean you man you can talk
yourself into rationalizing any of those
things in the moment right so I want to
back out and give you six six categories
I want you to look at in your life okay
and um you don't have to write these
down because they'll be available when
the show comes out but
um
the six categories I would line out for
you is the first thing I would sit down
and I would ask you to choose reality to
like really be honest about the reality
of several situations
okay and you for any number of reasons
and I'm sure you and I could talk for a
long long long long time
but you have
in your disposition that you're gonna
make sure everybody sees
a beautiful picture even if things are
really hard behind that picture is that
true
yes yes
I have a feeling that if your husband
was really mean to you one day nobody
would ever ever know
or if you were really really exhausted
and frustrated with your kid no one
would ever ever know
because you have become so gifted over
the course of time probably too because
you had to
at smiling and saying oh sure it's fine
everything's fine because you don't want
to be a burden to anybody and so I'd ask
you to look at
reality
like what is the state of your marriage
for real what's the state of your
workplace for real what's your state of
your friendships for real being a parent
your relationship with your parents I
want you to look at the landscape of the
relationships in your life that's number
one
in your workplace all that stuff number
two is I want you to begin to choose
freedom to look for places where other
people are deciding what you do
that might be if you owe money to
somebody
that might be in-laws that are making
demands of you that might be a calendar
that is super full and out of control
that might be uh any number of things
that are other people are demanding of
you
and you don't get to drive in the
driver's seat of your own life the third
one is connection we talked about that
earlier about relationships you might be
great on that one awesome the fourth one
is mindfulness and we'll we'll get there
in a second
really mindfulness is simply the gap
between
um
that feeling I want to do this thing
and actually doing it mindfulness is I'm
I'm having this thought but I'm not
gonna go I'm not gonna go through with
it right and then the next one is
belief this idea that you've got to have
something anchored into something bigger
than you are do you have a faith do you
have a faith belief system of any kind
um yeah I mean kind enough I'm not 100
practice but yeah that's okay yeah I'm
not going to prescribe one to you I'm
just going to say you have to have some
sense that I am not alone in the
universe I'm not I'm not a balloon that
somebody cut the string and I'm just
floating off aimlessly all by myself
because that body is going to always be
anxious because it's going to be
untethered no matter how how good it is
and the last one is you got to choose
health and healing that might be sleep
that might be going to counseling for
the first time and dealing with some
childhood trauma that might be
um any number of I got to deal with this
nagging knee injury or back injury I
just gotta I gotta get well and whole I
gotta quit drinking 45 energy drinks in
the morning before I go to work or
whatever the thing is here's here's the
picture I want you to have
if your life is a cup
and it's already filled to the brim with
all these things I just talked about
your body's lonely you got a chaotic
schedule you got a bunch of demands all
over on you all the time your
relationships aren't solid you're
untethered you're not well
then when something happens like your
boss hollers at you or somebody cuts you
off in traffic or your husband is snaps
at you
there's no there's no place for that
extra water to go when it gets poured
into the glass and it just spills over
everywhere
but if you keep the water in that glass
really low then when life happens when
somebody pours water in it it's got
plenty of space to absorb that water to
to capture that water right
and so
more practically speaking how serious
are you about stopping impulse shopping
how seriously do you just want to quit
100 like every time I bought something I
always like and I look and I I feel it's
got better
um I used to like almost every mom by
shoes clothes there's that and now like
I feel like okay it's been months now
but there's days that it's just
I would look at it and I said No and
then I go back to the website and then I
go back to the website and I keep like
no I don't need it and then eventually
invite
so I would tell you you're gonna have to
do what I had to do several years ago
which is I had to give my debit card to
my wife
I had to take it out of my possession
because I didn't control myself I
couldn't control myself
and mine was always taking people to
lunch oh I got it let's go to lunch
let's go to lunch go to lunch I'll go
get coffee let's go grab dinner
and so it wasn't shoes and shirts as
much as it was I was trying to buy
connection with people because I didn't
think people would want to hang out with
me just to hang out
and so I had to take radical steps I
disconnected Amazon Prime I didn't have
access to it I changed the code I didn't
have access I couldn't get in
and I didn't have my debit card so I
couldn't just go buy things willy-nilly
I had some cash in my wallet and that's
what I used to spend when it was gone it
was gone
but there's some really easy steps you
can take to make it to where I can you
can't just buy stuff
the harder thing will be
being very mindful when you get the
impulse to stop
and pull out a small little binder a
small little notebook that you might get
at like Walgreens or something like that
and just write down what is my body
trying to protect me from what is my
body trying to numb out from
and probably what you're going to find
is you're having problems at work
you're exhausted
your husband is amazing but you could
really use a lot a lot of work at home
with the kids because you're working
full-time too
it can be any number of those things in
those six categories but your body's
trying to just shut the system down
because the the glass is full
your can't take you can't take any more
and it just says hey let's throw this
thing in the neutral and we're going to
head off this way and just buy some
stuff somebody else might be like be
cutting somebody else might get another
drink and another drink another drink
somebody else might go to pornography
somebody else might go to any number of
things
that we're going to do just to numb out
and I'll tell you the same thing I tell
everybody Lila hey thank you so much for
calling
um hang on the line here I'm going to
send you a copy of my brand new book
building a non-anxious life
um we didn't even mean to set it up this
way but it's it's almost just a perfect
handoff for you so I'm going to send you
a copy of the book
um
but I tell everybody
you are worth not living a numbed out
life
you are you're creative for more than
that you're put here on Earth for more
than just to band it over how you feel
what you wanted what you think what you
need
and just go yeah
you're worth more than that your life is
worth more than that your marriage is
worth more than that your time with your
kids and your friends are worth more
than that your time spent at work is
worth more than that
so Lila I'll ask you I'll ask everybody
listening don't settle for a numbed out
life it's worth the work to head into
the storm and ask your body what are you
trying to protect me from what are you
trying to numb me out from what are you
trying to distract me from
and I gotta head right into the middle
of those storms
that's where the light is that's where
the healing is
thank you so so much for the call Lila
I'm so I'm so grateful that you call I'm
proud of you for calling
um hang on the line we'll get you hooked
up call anytime
anytime everybody
you're worth a peaceful non-exist Life
we'll be right back
hey deloney here all right it's time to
declutter you got a treadmill covered in
dust you got magazines from five years
ago piled up in the corner a garage you
can't even Park in and all that clutter
and mess can lead to anxiety to just
feeling burned out and overwhelmed when
you hang on to the wrong things for too
long it can lead to something else bad
sleep that's right you might have the
same nasty lumpy mattress you've had for
decades just sitting up there gross your
sleep is way too important for that and
you're way too important one of the
easiest things you can do to improve
your physical and mental health is
invest in refreshing sleep and that
includes having a great new mattress
like a dream cloud and right now dream
cloud is making it a no-brainer to
upgrade your mattress with an offer just
for our listeners 4 40 off of all
mattresses plus an additional fifty
dollars in savings
time to start prioritizing your sleep
clear out all the Clutter
get rid of that old mattress and go to
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
John deloney
that's dreamcloudsleep.com with code
all right we're back let's go out to
Baltimore home of the wire and talk to
the great Melissa what's up Melissa
hey Dr John how are you I'm great how
are you
good it's an honor to get to talk to you
today
thank you for calling how can I help
um so I guess I'm gonna cannonball in
um start off saying something
that I've never said out loud and I
guess I'll say it out loud to all 18
listeners okay I want to stop you before
you do it okay this is kind of my rule
of thumb when anybody says I've never
said this before
yeah I always want to stop them
and make sure I'm the right guy
okay am I the right guy
I think so okay I think so if you're
doing anything illegal I still have to
hold you accountable for that is that
cool
that's cool nothing illegal okay all
right
if you if you're if you're totally
comfortable for everybody listening
anytime somebody says I've never told
anybody this but I need to tell you
something so stop because if they tell
you something you might have to act on
it okay so Melissa I'm trusting you and
I promise I'll sit with you go for it
um I have been abusing pain medication
for over four years now prescription
pain medication
um I had a previous problem with it in
my 20s
um I ended up going to treatment I was
clean for five years
um and then about 10 years ago I was in
a car accident and injured my spine
pretty bad
um ended up having to have spinal
surgery
um and
have been in pain management for about
yeah four or four years now
um my husband and my family don't know
that I'm taking opioid pain medication
uh I've never told them I think because
of the
stigma of what happened you know when I
was in my 20s when I didn't have
legitimate pain but I live with chronic
pain every day of my life now
um and
I just
I I'm ashamed
um in a way but at the same time I feel
Justified a little bit
but I'm constantly beating myself up
over it because
I am constantly running out of my pain
medication early and everything is great
until that point you know I have energy
I do well at work I participate in my
life you know I can concentrate on
things but then as soon as that
prescription runs out everything comes
crashing down and it's like I just crawl
into a black hole for you know as long
as it is until the next time you know I
am able to to get my prescription
refilled
um okay can I can tell you a few things
that are hard
yeah
well first of all thank you for saying
that out loud I'm really proud of you
I would hug you if you were sitting here
and I probably wouldn't say anything for
the next five or ten minutes I just sit
here with you
thank you
how did that feel saying that out loud
um
out of body kind of experience
you'll probably feel some instant relief
and then the shame Waters will slowly
start circulating back through and a
little bit to fill up that space
I want you to know I'm proud of you okay
I just want to say that out loud
here's some hard truths that you know
um but it's just gotten a little bit
hazy
your family knows
they may not know exactly what
but they know
and that idea that you can focus and
everything is better and I become more
of a laser
that's the addiction talking again
yeah
because it's not right because I promise
you your colleagues are like man what is
up I promise you
and so there's this moment what what
made you say I've got I've got to get
I've gotta say this out loud I've gotta
I've got to do something that's
different
something happened
nothing happened I just feel like I've
been doing this dance for a while where
you know I find the gift of desperation
to stop and then
I just don't have you know the willpower
and then I think of like the fact that
I do have legitimate chronic pain but I
need help with holding myself
accountable because obviously I'm not
doing it well and you can have chronic
pain that's managed in different ways
than just yeah Throne opiates at it
right
um all right so let's walk through this
together
you call a meeting tonight with your
husband and you take him out and you say
I have to have a hard conversation with
you
and you say I've been using for four
years and we both know that I've got
these prescriptions but
um
I'm burning through the prescriptions
I'm even getting some other ones from
another doctor from friends
um
I've reached a point where I can't
control this
what happens then next
um
I fear that he would never look at me
the same way again
because
I think
it's not so much the using but
the line
and the hiding things into the turret
like the Betrayal
that I think would really hit him harder
than anything else
and
I'm just terrified that if I have that
conversation if I
yeah that he would never look at me the
same way again and that it might end up
ruining our marriage
what's the chances he reaches over gets
up from where he is and comes and hugs
you and holds you so tight you can
hardly breathe
I honestly don't see that happening okay
what if you told them I'm going to tell
you something and when it's over
it's going to be hard for you
but I need you to get up and come over
and sit by me and just hug me and not
say anything for a minute
and if you told him I'm embarrassed
about the lies I'm embarrassed about the
shame but I'm sick
and we've been through this before and I
got to go through it again
I think it's probably writing all that
stuff down and reading that out in some
shape form or fashion but one of the
most common things I hear on the front
end of somebody coming clean is
I'm afraid everybody's going to do x y
and z
and it just doesn't always happen that
way sometimes yeah people react poorly
or they re they make it about them and
all that
yeah but sometimes I don't
and let me tell you this
you know me on if you listen to this
show I'm always dude I want to go to the
ends of the Earth to try to save
marriages because I think marriage is a
beautiful thing
but I'd rather your marriage
I'd rather you'll go separate ways than
you die and you know how this ends
and you got little ones too right
I don't actually no kids okay good yeah
okay no kids and not planning on kids
okay just pause
when you use before
the the the pain
what were you cut what were you duct
taping over
um
just general anxiety
social anxiety
um
just feeling
I don't know a lack of self-confidence
you know there wasn't anything there
wasn't any major event any trigger I
didn't have you know any trauma in my
childhood I
I mean legitimately had a very good
childhood and I have two loving parents
who you know would do absolutely
anything for me
um and I think it just
my marriage
um
all right let me say something really
harsh okay yeah
I question how strong
the buying the bounding The Binding is
in your marriage
if you think you come to him in a moment
of illness and he bails
either that's the addiction talking or
your marriage is is not a secure Bond
it's not a secure attachment
I think it's more of the addiction
talking because
I mean
when I'm not having this kind of
conversation and I just kind of
think think about it I mean he
he's always told me you know that he's
in for the Long Haul he's not
he's never going to leave me you know he
believes in just marriage as an
institution and
I just like I don't
I don't think that he would actually
leave I think what I'm more afraid of is
like I said him just never looking at me
the same way again
and just
going through the motions and me not
being able to so don't dress rehearse
tragedy your dress rehearsing tragedy
don't invent problems that haven't
happened yet and try to solve them in
the present
yeah give him an opportunity to step up
and give him a road map to what that
looks like
here's the truth you've been through
this before
getting off this is brutal
yeah
going to AAA again what you gotta do is
brutal
yeah
going through this process will be very
difficult and you're worth every second
of it
Have you listened to uh if you haven't
already I would love for you to go
listen to
armchair expert with Dax Shepard and his
co-host Monica and the episode is called
day seven
and his claim to fame was 15 years
sobriety
and he was a mentor for countless people
he was a sponsor for countless people
then he had an accident
and he had to reckon with starting over
because he used again and started hiding
him
and it's one of the most beautiful
heartbreaking hard
but truly extraordinary pictures of what
this actually looks like
I want you to listen to the episode
because his friend Monica holds him
accountable
and
she says I love you in the same in the
same conversation
and there's ownership and there's
accountability and there's heartbreak
and there's shame and there's
forgiveness and the whole thing it's a
beautiful picture of it in real time but
it really applies here
but I want you to remember two important
things number one Secrets will kill you
yeah
right
yeah and so you got to have this
conversation sooner rather than later
the second thing is
you're worth being well and you're worth
being sober
will you commit to having this
conversation with him
yeah I will
I have to I know I have to I'm really
proud of you
thank you
so I want you to listen to that episode
day seven we'll see if we can find a
link in the show notes it's been a year
or two
um since it came out
um
and feel free to give me a call feel
free to have him give me a call on the
back end after you have this
conversation okay you can both call into
the show talk to you both at the same
time
um I want you when you sit down with him
to already have a plan like I'm going to
a meeting in the morning
I don't want it to just be an open-ended
thing where he's kind of off untethered
all of a sudden and also like I said
give him a path back tell him I I know
I'm so full of Shame right now I can
hardly keep my eyes open
I just need to know that you love me and
will you hug me
yeah
and
tomorrow when we wake up I would love it
if you made breakfast and I'd love it if
you drove me down to my meeting or I'd
love it if we had coffee together and we
didn't talk about it and then I'm gonna
go to the meeting and you ask me about
how the meeting went
I'm actually going to a meeting tonight
good for you
so maybe after the meeting you tell them
and maybe after you get a sponsor
tonight you guys get somebody's number
tonight you got somebody you can call
after the meeting because it means might
be hard it might go awful
yeah but it has to happen right
it does because yeah I I know like you
said I know how this ends yeah
I've seen it happen to too many of my
friends
over the years
but on the other side of it I've got
some friends who are sober and their
families are incredible and they laugh a
lot and they're silly and funny and they
have good marriages and they've got good
jobs
so there's light on the other side too
and make no mistake I'm not gonna
sugarcoat it opioids your demon man
it will hang on your soul they're tough
they're tough tough tough tough
there's biochemical reasons for it
they're tough
[Music]
group of people go with you
you're worth being well my sister I'm so
so proud to call anytime have your
husband call anytime y'all call together
I'll walk with you as long as you'll
have me
let me know how this conversation goes
let me know how tonight's meeting goes
I'm so proud of you we'll be right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hallow.com deloney
all right let's roll out to Princeton
New Jersey and talk to the Great and
Powerful Conrad what's up Conrad
Dr John what up
uh just rocking on to the break of dawn
yeah yeah what's up man how we doing
I'm doing all right all right let's
let's get to it dude we're not gonna
help
I'm really looking about how do I go
about getting my friends back together
or just to figure out how to navigate
Our Lives moving forward I've had the
same Core group of friends for the last
15 20 years and uh I love them all
they're all amazing folks but uh the
past few years there's been like a rift
in the group and it all really came to a
head a week ago I was getting everyone
together I just wanted to treat
everybody to dinner and you know have a
good time with everybody and it was made
clear that uh some folks didn't want to
be there they just flat out didn't want
to be there if certain folks were were
coming along
um so there's this huge Rift between
everyone uh I'm still friends with
everyone but it sort of put me in the
middle of things so I really want to
respect my friends and their wishes to
sort of grow as people but uh respect
the other folks involved at the same
time and I'm really struggling with it
yeah man how old are you
uh 30 this year this year
well congratulations you're almost dead
now because you're really old just
kidding
um uh I was gonna lay it out it's hard
man but this is how it happens
is that happens
there's friendships that you look back
on that mean everything and we have 10
years 15 years 20 years of history and
we did everything together
and they're gone
or one friend hooks up with somebody
else's wife or one friend gets divorced
or one friend you find out abuse their
kid or one friend passes away one friend
moves
and the world of trying to hold it all
together as a 30 year old becomes really
hard if you've ever listened to this
show I'm always talking about how hard
it's the worst having kids I mean I'm
the kids having kids is awesome making
friends at 35.
I don't do enough job I don't do a good
enough job talking to how heartbreaking
it is when your friendships change at
30.
yeah it's sort of I'm because I still
talk to everyone and it was like you
know just this week we saw some folks
and they were like oh do you still talk
to someone so and it's like I'm in this
weird position because it's like yeah we
had dinner a couple nights ago but
they're just not talking to you okay why
is that a weird why is that a weird
position for you
ah
sort of you know it's because it sounds
like you have have positioned yourself
as The Wedding Planner like a JLo movie
and you're like it's your job to make
sure everybody's do it
and it's your job to love well and be
honest with people and to allow yourself
to be loved and so if they have Rifts
cool man I'm still gonna hang out
and if they ever put you in a position
to say hey if you're with them you're
not with me
then you got a choice to make
I mean luckily I have
um a good friend of mine when we were
planning this whole thing he said listen
um I just want to be you know upfront
with you I'm sort of grown as a person I
really don't want to you know hang out
with these folks anymore it's not my cup
of tea I'm not going to tell you who to
hang out with
um and like I appreciated him being so
upfront with it but it's like it's when
Friends start asking about oh what about
this person what about this person and
it's like you know dude
you know I should just be honest with
them and tell them
that's not your story to tell I would
just saying yeah I would say that's the
part I'm struggling with yeah they
didn't make it
yeah
like you don't have to get an
explanation
oh it's you're right it is rough because
it's like you know it's it's not the
whole group it's like you know a couple
folks and then everybody else that's
right and it's just I feel like I was
always like include folks and bring them
into the fold but now that it's like
this this distinct division
um but you're not you're not you're not
bringing people into the fold you're
trying to
you're they're trying to leave and
you're trying to force them to stay
that's different there's something about
including people who are on the margins
people who are on the outside people
that you think would be great in the
Gang
there's another thing when people in the
gang are like hey it's run its course
for me I'm out and you're like no no you
gotta stay you gotta stay you got you
gotta like we're all gonna
that's a different story that's you
propping up your picture of what this is
supposed to look like not honoring the
person on the margins
yeah I realize that sucks the way I just
said that no no you're right it's like
um I love them and I care about them and
I need to honor their wishes respect
that they want to grow and yeah what if
they think that this guy just sucks
right it's not even about growth I don't
like that dude he always gets drunk and
acts like an idiot or it always hits on
my wife or whatever it's rough yeah um
it's really respecting them and
respecting their Journey with it
um
there's no like bad blood there's not
like somebody slept with somebody's wife
or something like that but it's just you
know people growing as people and it's
like
I guess it's coming to terms with the
idea that I had for the future and like
you know oh you've got you know work
together and go through like all right
having kids and doing all that and like
sort of have those people going through
it with you and accepting the idea that
that picture that I built for myself is
a little different now and that you know
people are changing and I can't control
that
one of my
one of my favorite people I've ever had
the opportunity to be friends with
um
he was in my wedding I was I
participated in his
um
I had a bad situation A housing
situation and I moved into his kitchen
literally he got rid of his kitchen
table and moved my bed into his kitchen
table in his kitchen
uh he's an amazing guy
and we went to We Were Young
Knuckleheads we went to Blink 182
concert
well years ago years ago
and then I went again recently
and I texted him a picture
said man I missed this and he goes man
me too that was that was those are good
times
and if I tell you what if I called him
and said I really need some help he
would be here in no time
because I love him he loves me he loves
my family he's friends with my wife I I
love his wife we're connected we always
will be but it's different now
he's an executive in some big fancy
company we live 17 hours away by car I'm
a YouTuber for God's sake like right so
it happened
and if I could do anything to flip that
I would
because I missed the guy in my life
he's one of the greatest friends a guy
could have
and
I'm so excited for his professional
opportunities and for him and his family
and all the things and I know he has the
same for me and so it's just making
peace and grieving what was and making
peace with what is
and then I've got to do the hard scary
work of making friends in my local
community and that's terrible
but here we are right and that's just
one dude man there's like multiple guys
that like remember when remember when
Remember When
and here we are
and I wish it wasn't right around 30
when it all happens but that's a pretty
common time for people to have their
first kid people have their first
breakup people to be like hey am I
drinking anymore whatever the thing is I
don't go to church anymore I do go to
church I'm super Jesus freak whatever
the thing is
it just happens around this time
oh man nobody really talks about it they
do they lose the show effectively but
well they don't talk about this like hey
things will change I appreciate you
calling here's what I would tell you to
do next time somebody and and Bravo to
him for Having the courage to set a
boundary right okay man I'm just um if
that guy's gonna be here I'm just gonna
bail it's cool you'll have a great time
Bravo to him for not being a drama queen
about it not not causing a bunch of if
he comes I'm out and if you choose him
he didn't do that he acted like a
grown-up right so Bravo to him and
Bravo for you for respecting him and I
want you to when that happens
literally it's gonna sound cheesy put
your hand on your body where you feel it
is it in your chest is it in your
shoulders like when your body's like hey
I'm not gonna make it and you think of
that room and only 80 of the gang is
there right
feel that for a second and be like man I
wish everybody would be there it sucks
and then you blow it out and you put
your hand on your chest and you say cool
I'm proud of you for making making a
decision and I'm gonna go ahead with a
party I'm gonna do what I'm gonna do
that's the best you can do and if
somebody says hey have you seen so and
so like yeah we grabbed dinner the other
day
oh really why aren't they here I didn't
want to make it they couldn't make it
better things going on that's all you
got to do
you don't got to tell other people's
stories
but it's mostly you come into terms with
people have the right to come and go and
they will come and go in your life and
it hurts and it's hard and it's
completely normal
and the one thing you can control is I
am going to be a person that surrounds
myself with friends and Community it's
kind of guy I'm gonna be I'm gonna have
people
even when I'm tired even when I don't
want to I'm gonna have people
I'm proud of you brother thanks for
calling man
and thanks for reminding me I need to
talk more about
that 28 to 33 year old season when
everybody kind of starts splintering and
moving on and there's that sense of loss
and hey let's keep the text threads
going and the memes going
but it's all just not the same
find some new Buddies to invite into the
fold and make sure you stay connected to
the guy that stepped out
[Music]
sorry the pictures are changing man
as Blink-182 said
I guess this is growing up we'll be
right back
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-interest life today for just 20
bucks at John deloney.com
all right we are back listen we have a
new segment on the show and if you've
listened to this show for any period of
time you know we're always inventing new
segments
most of the time they last
um one segment but we're gonna give this
one a go because I'm pretty hyped about
this
so we've gotten several emails or calls
and around the same theme and so I'm
calling on you listeners
calling on you listeners a to pre-order
the book johndalene.com Shameless plug
that I just feel kind of gross that I
just did that but go to johndalene.com
pre-order the book and
this new um segment in honor of the
Great and Powerful Taylor Swift is
called
I'm the problem is it me
question mark I know she doesn't have a
question mark but alas people are right
in and say hey am I the jerk am I the
idiot is this all is this my fault
and so I would love to keep this thing
going and instead of doing the lyrics of
the day we're just gonna end the show
with am I the problem and I think
that'll be a blast will you say Kelly
just make sure you keep them short keep
them short okay because we can't do long
ones since it's just in this last
segment so keep them short and make sure
you put in there am I the problem
and then also after we read it and we'll
all talk about it then we want our fans
to go on to Social and to reviews and
tell us what they think what they think
all right so today the first installment
of the first installment ever of am I
the problem is it me
question mark
is from Kimberly monks in Utah
Kim Wright
am I the jerk
my husband gets up early to ride his
bike before work usually between 3 40
and 4 a.m ish
yikes he has a hard time waking up to
his alarm I'm already telling you no I
usually wake up to wake him up to tell
him to turn his alarm off then there's
the snooze it takes me a lot longer to
fall back asleep than he does so when
his snooze keeps going off I've
basically been awake the whole time I
prefer to wake up around 5 to 5 30 for
my workout he then gets upset with me
and eventually firmly at uh he gets
upset
he then gets upset with me for
eventually firmly asking him to turn off
his snooze or put his phone under his
pillow or just get up he interprets the
experience as me yelling at him in the
morning you probably are it is 4 AM and
then he's in a bad mood and he just
won't go because he's a baby
we have serious communication issues but
I can't see how I'm in the wrong here
what a clown he has slept on a blow up
mattress downstairs the past two nights
he'll show you because he doesn't like
waking up mad
so
we'll take uh we'll take opinions from
the booth I think he wants to be a guy
who wakes up at 4am or 3 40 to ride his
bike but he's not
and he is just a guy that creates
unnecessary noise at 3 40 to 4 A.M
and he likes to tell people I got up
early at four to ride my bike this
morning I'm a guy that gets up before
you're not you're a guy that sets his
alarm for four and then hit snooze and
snooze and snooze and the woman you
chose to share a bed with is like God
Almighty can we just sleep in like
normal people so no I think he's the
jerk and I also think he's acting like a
baby for being like I'm sleeping on
my blow-up mattress I don't want to wake
up mad you don't want to wake up mad
actually wake up and then get up then
you wouldn't be mad or be say you know
what Jocko 4 30 a.m I concede it you win
you know who I'm not David Goggins I'm
just not so I'm gonna sleep until 5 30
which is still way before all of Earth
and I'm gonna work out then near near
and then you don't have to be an idiot
and I realized saying someone's an idiot
is harsh but dude you know I know
because this was me homie this was me
I'm a broke it's a before am and I run
48 miles and whatever and then my sweet
wife would just be like hey
if you set your alarm at 4 will you get
up and actually go
and not just lay there and hit snooze
and snooze and snooze and snooze until I
want to stab you not in the back but in
the front so you'll feel it when you die
like am I crazy what do you think oh
he's 100 The Jerk on this one I would be
putting my pillow over his face
and you listen to enough murder podcast
they would never figure it out that's
right Jenna what do you think yeah he's
the problem 100 he's the problem I can't
believe he said that I don't like waking
up mad I know maybe then don't hit
snooze a thousand times
and by the way uh Kimberly monks you are
100 are yelling you know why because
every rational person would yell if
every day of their life an alarm went
off at 3 40 and then at 3 50 and then at
four and then at 4 10 and then 4 20
everyone would yell
at Gandhi would start yelling at that
time
every major monks who have vows of
Silence they've taken vows of silence
for centuries they would come out of the
grave and be like turn it off you're
exactly right
he is the problem
not you so congratulations our first
inaugural am I the problem in this case
no it's him it's him hey send these in
go to John deloney.com ask keep them
brief and put in the headline am I the
problem is it me would love to hear it
and we're gonna roll off the ending the
show with lyrics of the day and I'd love
to have these have more and more of
these take care be kind to one another
stay in school don't do drugs all that
stuff and hey
tell somebody today look them in the
eyes and tell them that you love him and
you're grateful for them I'll see you
soon
[Music]